Express 25 degrees
Celsius as a temperature
in degrees Fahrenheit using
the formula Fahrenheit, or F,
is equal to 9/5 times the
Celsius degrees plus 32.
So they're telling us that
we have 25 degrees Celsius.
So we could put
that in for C here,
and we'll get the temperature
in Fahrenheit degrees.
So let's do that.
So we'll get F is equal
to 9/5-- now for C,
we're going to put in
25-- times 25 plus 32.
And now we can simplify this
before we multiply 25 times 9.
Remember, this is the same
thing as 9/5 times 25/1.
We can essentially divide the
numerator and the denominator
of our eventual product by 5.
If we divide 25 by 5, we get 5.
If we divide 5 by 5, we get 1.
So this boils down
to 9 times 5 plus 32.
So our Fahrenheit
degrees are going
to be 9 times 5 is
45 plus 32 degrees.
Or it's equal to
45 plus 32 is 77,
so this is 77
degrees Fahrenheit.